the magazine was founded in 1828 this is
the biggest event in the spectators long
history should Britain leave the
European Union all of the chairs of
voting slips for remain for leave or for
undecided let me ask this Kendall to
kick off the debate for the remain
Seidel is Kendall there is not a single
serious credible independent
organization that thinks we'd be better
off out the CBI says brexit would cause
a serious shock to our economy the World
Bank oacd
International Monetary Fund and ifs all
agree our economy would take a hit we
have a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to
vote to take back the independence
self-governance and control of this
country's laws of this country's courts
and crucially of this country's borders
when a European law is made there is
nothing that you the voters the House of
Commons or the British government can do
to reverse a single piece of European
legislation in many ways this debate is
about who we are what Great Britain is
what are we going to be as a country now
and in the future I think the only way
that we could maximize control over our
own destiny over our own economic
fortunes over safety on our streets over
the quality of the air we breathe is by
working hand in glove with our nearest
neighbors in the European Union the
future generations of this country will
be safe
we'll be better off we'll be stronger by
remaining in the European Union thank
you very much
the --use government the Commission is
unelected and cannot be removed by any
of us or elections and that fact alone
is reason to me
enough to reject the EU it isn't
democratic it is exactly the opposite it
is corporate and anti-democratic the EU
isn't perfect of course it needs reform
but I don't think any of the three of us
are arguing that and actually that isn't
the question that we've been asked on
the 23rd of June we are being are simply
do we believe we are safer stronger and
better off in than out Britain has
always pulled sovereignty and worked
with other nations if you took the leave
campaigners argument to its logical
conclusion then we sovereign nation
there will probably be North Korea
because they don't really work with
anybody I'm inviting you to make me
redundant and indeed in the bargain make
nitrile redundant and I wouldn't be
doing that if I were not confident that
there will be plenty of openings for
newly unemployed MEP s in the boom that
will come to this country after we've
left the European Union why do we tie
ourselves to the one part of the world
that is not experiencing significant
economic growth every continent on this
planet has grown over the past decade
except Antarctica and Europe we come to
the moment of the vote to remain leave
our undecided
can I ask first of all who is still
undecided a good view is the answer who
wants to vote to leave
and who wants to vote to remain well
leaves have it the leaves have it thank
you all for coming tonight and
participating being such a wonderful
audience a huge round of applause for
our wonderful debaters